the best lesson that I took or that we
took as a company I think in humbleness
is yes you have a big Vision you need to
start small you want to make sure that
you're creating value today for everyone
in the value chain for the main user for
the main buyer for the person that's
around you but we got to that by making
a lot of mistakes we made
a lot of different changes in the way we
spoke about it and the way we introduced
it and the way we built it in the way we
sold of Mater
but it took a lot of time welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm honored to be joined by gal
shaol the co-founder and chief
technology and product officer of auguri
a machine health company building a
world where people can always rely on
the machines that matter he oversees
value delivery to customers via Services
operations and products and drives
technical Innovation at the company
prior to founding augury gal was the
head of software development at endymed
and medical devices startup and a
firmware engineer at Zoran a cheap
Manufacturing Company he holds a BSC in
computer science from the Israel
Institute of Technology
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me how are you
I'm doing well very happy to be here
we're just caught a cold but other than
that everything's great
well thank you for joining me
nevertheless it's going to be a great
20-minute conversation and we're gonna
in a second I'm gonna ask you about this
uh awesome looking window behind you and
what what is going inside on inside
there but you're the chief product
technology officer at augury and the
looking at machine failures and over the
last 10 years been building an
incredible company that that is doing
really really cool things and so I'm
really excited to hear about You Know
Your Role there and what the company is
doing and the different the domain that
you're in and the different insights
that you've had so tell me what it is
that's behind you right now and then
we'll dive into your actual day job
yeah so it's not very far from my day
job but specifically this one's not for
the company I work for yeah it's an
alpha product for a company called agua
Farm we had an amazing product manager
that left to work there
it's a
growing for the family right so you can
see there are a lot of green things
growing and they're managing it from an
app
and I'm testing it and eating it
for me and for the rest of my family so
we're all having fun with that
awesome okay so now I can and now I can
be at peace with with my curiosity uh
yeah just for context I didn't let you
tell me before we started the podcast
because I knew everybody would be
curious okay take me back you know 10 11
years or so what's happening in the
world what what where are you at in your
life that's getting into augury
yes
um so I was a few years after
engineering pool working for a medical
device startup
with the background there's a naval
officer in Israel
and working for a small company
relatively small startup roughly 20
people or so leading software there
trying to do different
things most of the startups around us it
was on late 2011.
where
might take you back in time because
startups usually are not that
long but we started where most of the
things around us were a social mobile
and gear location everyone was talking
about that everything had to go to
mobile everything had to add some
localization aspect or understanding of
that
and we were looking at kind of The Next
Step we're like right what's up
after kind of this consumer phase right
how does it go back to Enterprise where
does it things are going to go Sarah and
I met each other at the technion we were
talking about startups
forever
um
and then when this specific opportunity
presented itself and we can talk
specifically about that there was
something about
Industrials and real world problems kind
of with the physical world and getting
all the good things that happen with
digital and nice screens and appealing
interfaces and intuitive things
happening that just didn't go back to
Industrial didn't go back to Enterprise
for so long
and we started working on something like
that right I was working in a medical
device startup had a problem in a
machine could you could hear it but
nothing in the machine told you it's
wrong
so I was working on other things uh at
the time and I called them to ask for a
solution can we just put something there
that would hear the problem right
because that's the indicator that I'm
hearing so why don't
other Assad was working in similar
correlations between
physical sounds in AI it was at a time
where kind of image processing was
really moving forward in Ai and or
machine learning was really involved in
that and everything around sound wasn't
really there around text and language
that it was but
around kind of
physical sounds kind of things that come
from nature from the surroundings of us
wasn't a thing so cool
um so we started working together and we
understood very early on that we want to
do something it's now right it's before
we had kids it's before kind of families
Drew we had just enough money from in
order to get started we thought about it
like an MBA program right we'll do kind
of an OJT for an MBA we'll take what it
would cost and spend it on our first
company but we'll build it right right
so we had a curriculum of learnings and
we had things that we were doing for the
first two years
and we got a lot of lap
for investors because we were pretty
early on iot wasn't a thing Internet of
Things wasn't a phrase yet industry 4.0
wasn't coined yet
Industrial Revolution wasn't there there
were people still speaking about the
previous Industrial Revolution right so
a lot of the things emerged while we're
already
in there so it's a privilege to see an
industry like that emerge wouldn't
happen with us and around us
tell me a little bit about your process
as an entrepreneur in an emerging
industry how how did you manage the
tension or the dissonance between
you know where you are seeing the world
where the world is now and how do you
help people whether it's customers
investors employees how do you bridge
that gap for everybody because you're
sort of living on a different planet
sometimes and you have to constantly
come back down to reality and while also
living towards division
yes I would say that
real real advantage of being there early
is that you get to make the most amount
of mistakes more than anyone else you
start speaking about AI to Industrial
people or to people on the ground on the
production floor
and they don't really understand what
you're
what do you want from them right so you
learn to be humble very early
and you start speaking some industrial
language and
with VCS and you understand again that
it's not their realm so you're
constantly trying to be this bridge not
by yourself right but you need a lot of
help
important to make it happen in order to
really bridge that Gap I think
the best lesson that I took or that we
took as a company I think in humbleness
is yes you have a big Vision you need to
start small you want to make sure that
you're creating value today for everyone
in the value chain for the main user for
the main buyer for the person that's
around you but we got to that by making
a lot of mistakes we made
a lot of different changes in the way we
spoke about it and the way we introduced
it and the way we built it and the way
we sold it later
but it took a lot of time
and so during that time
take me back really to the founding for
a second of of how you saw what was the
division that you had for this world
what was the vision for augury back then
and and then I'd love to sort of fast
forward to today and where you're at now
and how you're seeing the world today
and obviously talking about what it
means to be both Chief product and CTO
yeah
um
so I would say that back then
people
maybe were not
our main focus at least at the beginning
but it was all machines are going to
interact with each other they're all
going to be connected
and with that connection a lot of power
would
come to everyone who wants to use that
right if every machine becomes a sensor
in a way right every machine tells you
what it's doing what it's trying to do
how it's behaving
um
done a lot of big things would evolve
from that
I think that's where we started it's a
bit of a technological vision of all
right we have a take of this is where
technology is going to head right every
Center or every machine is going to be
connected
and entrance made backwards what it's
doing
I think where we
evolve to is the understanding that what
we can bring to the table outside of the
Technologies though
this interaction between people and
machine
and make the world better in every
possible way right there there are
things around kind of companies profits
that needs to evolve and they can make
production more efficient and be
create more wealth while doing that and
invest that somewhere else
it can improve their employees life
and everyone around them right so if
they Empower people on the production
line to be more data people they can be
more autonomous in decision making they
can learn more they can earn more they
can have easier ships they don't need to
come in the middle of the night because
they're gonna know right so they're
going to have a lot of prosperity with
their people and they're going to help
the environment right so they're gonna
have less
emissions and they're gonna have less
weight
while at it so they're gonna so then
this balance of people
profit and planet right so kind of
something from the late 90s which always
felt like a trade-off between kind of
those two elements is all of a sudden
not a trade-off it's an evolutionary
step towards that that it goes together
if you invest more in your people you're
gonna
create less pollution and you're going
to make more profit and understanding
that's even feasible
today for manufacturing which is what a
the biggest problems in pollution today
and becoming a part of the solution for
that is a big privilege and being a part
of that vision and helping finding that
Vision forward
I would say to your question one more
sentence go ahead
that so what we learned along the
journey is to dream bigger
that it's not only a product it's an
industry change that shifts right so as
you stand at the position where you
believe
that everything you said at the
beginning is actually feasible and it's
actually doable and it's actually
happening in the world right where can
you look at the Horizon and the ability
to dream bigger is something that is a
big privilege to where we stand today
so I want to take you back just one more
time to you know September 2011 as
you're starting as you're starting you
know this company
you were an engineer before that you
know trained at the Tiffany on
um did software engineering a couple of
places and then started the company's
co-founder and CTO and you're looking
now
you know a little more than 11 years
down the line a lot of volume of capital
you know in transactions a lot of
different customers a big team that
you're managing
I mean what was that like for you making
that leap from you know a software
engineer to all of a sudden being you
know a co-founder of a Visionary startup
where a second ago you tell me that you
know what you really learned is that you
need to dream bigger than what you what
you may be dreaming currently
yeah
I think kind of being a first-time
founder especially coming from
engineering school and having Sarah as a
co-founder
uh is that you assume that you don't
know anything all right we know one
piece of building a company and then you
come with really fresh eyes to
do a lot of new things right we don't
know Finance
now what all right let's see what
courses should we take what should we
learn how fast can we learn that can we
be can we know enough in order to be
dangerous right can we know enough in
order to hire the right person can we
know enough in order to build the first
budget in order to get some funding in
order to hire someone that would manage
Finance right and go through for
marketing and sales in Biz Dev and
building a category and but it was
constantly being very curious and very
learning
driven
I think that what allowed us to be very
diligent on product like hey this
doesn't do what we wanted it to do I
don't and being kind of not afraid of
the answer no it doesn't work
and then this
correlation between we don't know
anything but we can learn everything
type of thing so this I don't know
humble brag type of uh
Behavior hey I don't know this but hey
give me a Wii let's talk in a week I'll
be a bit more educated in a week right
what I can learn in 20 hours is a lot
do you want to invest it in other things
right what I took up from it for my life
I start a new hobby every year and I
decide if I want to keep it after the
first 20 hours where you learn just
enough to feel that you suck
or that you don't know right or
understand what are the even the terms
of being good at this
and then you understand kind of if you
want to grow there if you don't if
you're gonna
bring someone else that is gonna do that
you're gonna drop it then never do it
again and it's true for the company and
it's true for for me it's those truths
for my life as well
so now 11 years then where we're a dog
breed today and what what is your sort
of what is your role now in this whole
world
yeah
um so I think very early on and I'll
definitely today culture was a very big
color of what we felt is important right
so if we're driving for a great vision
that includes people willing the people
that are with us to be on board so a
very vision mission vision and Mission
driven company team that is very
autonomous and works almost kind of by
its own to make a lot of decisions and
drives
with that seeking of truths type of
habit right it's kind of if something
doesn't work just keep breaking it until
it does or say that this is not the
direction and built it towards somewhere
else and you need to build a culture
that is very safe in order to be able to
say hey the thing that you asked for me
that it's not it right we're not going
to win with that it's not good enough
right so so the ability to move a lot of
the decision
down the line or putting decisions close
to where
the action is actually going to happen
or the operation is actually going to
happen as a big task of what I'm doing
today
easier when it's a 10 people company
it's a bit harder whether it's a 400
people
team that has driven across the ocean
and some of it came within with an M A
we recently had right so being able to
drive that culture
it is a big p
I think what I'm doing today is is two
things right it's making sure that our
core
stays very strong with product Market
fit that we have on machine health
and
around supporting everything that our
sales and marketing team need
and on the side of it making sure that
the incubation zone right or things that
we're building that are new
are not being Swept Away by the machine
that we're building to scale right
because the thing that you need to do
for Innovation not necessarily the thing
that you need to do in order to scale
products and we need to be in in a bit
of different tracks
and kind of things that you're building
for growth and think that you you know
that are already growing and you need to
feel that engine and perfect them it's a
bit of a different plan I think that my
role is making sure that at least the
things that are net new are being
protected this Innovation is still our
biggest driver as a company
and so if you're looking now at
you know a landscape of young
entrepreneurs going on their Journey
regardless of what what companies you
know they're building or their ideas and
it sounds like you're definitely the
right person to to be thoughtful about
this and to reflect back because of the
different lessons you've learned in the
intentionality with which you you went
on to this journey
how are you thinking about you know this
journey in retrospective to young
entrepreneurs today and obviously the
world is a little bit different than it
was but people are people Innovation is
innovation and and so what should young
entrepreneurs be keeping in mind as they
embark on this 11-year Journey where
hopefully at the end of it they can say
that now they're leading more than 400
person team strong whose goal is to keep
the core going and to continue
innovating
yeah
um
but I'll try to summarize some of it but
I think it's a it's a broad conversation
right but I think the very
the founding team that you're
that you're starting with co-founders
maybe the first five people that you
bring along really matters are really
gonna shape your
future because that's the people that
you're gonna be inspired by most of the
time yes you can watch an amazing Ted or
listen to this great podcast but then it
would be 20 minutes you'd listen to
another one that would be 40 and then
you spend another 14 hours with those
two to four people in a room
that are eating your brain and talking
all the time and speaking and debating
and that's your main source for
inspiration so if they're bringing the
best out of you
completing you in many ways right making
provoking your thought making you be
angry maybe but right but then you leave
and you come up with a better solution
tomorrow
that's a very good indicator you're in
the right team in the right place
uh so kind of being the best version of
yourself
if there would say that Tsar is a
long-term thinker my co-founder and and
I'm sometimes I made me more impulsive
or when I get
things for tomorrow but The Balancing
Act of both of us there was a
was a lot of good things and over the
years sometimes it changed right I
already started talking about too much
about why or too much about hey let's
think about it in terms of scale and he
was like no we just need to get this for
tomorrow and that's it then and I think
that The Balancing Act and the ability
to balance each other out in hard times
when someone's afraid when someone's in
a bad spot if they can lift you up
and if you can lift them up
when they need a hand I think that's a
the best advice I have there
learning curiosity is mandatory and how
do you manage fear I think is is an
aspect that I would uh not keep aside to
call me a little bit more how you manage
your fear
um
so I think at first it was something
that I wasn't able to recognize I was
doing it or it was just a part of
the way we encountered most
fears but one of us would take charge of
it and and
most of the time it was like turning on
all the lights and driving straight at
it it's not hiding away from it it's not
putting it aside it's like all right
it's called counter phobia but it's kind
of it's a defense mechanism where you
think that the best defense now is not
to Hideaway it's not to start telling
excuses it to just run at it they say
hey this is a problem let's call it even
a crisis and run right at it and not
talk about anything else but that
event
um it makes you sometimes kind of very
aggressive because people are not even
willing to speak about it yet they're
not sure you already have a fully baked
plan of how we're gonna operate uh
when kovitz started there was a lot of
fear and tons of uncertainty around
and it made sense so we gathered I
gathered the kind of the team of people
who likes war in my team I don't have a
kind of a better way to describe it we
have people that are good in peacetime
and are great where they're saying
drawing and flourishing you can cook new
flowers and the offices there and now we
need to renovate and now we need to do
this event and we have some people who
are there for wartime
all right we don't know we don't
understand how customers are going to
join us we don't understand how we're
going to the player solution we don't
understand how to work remotely really
well we're too small we need to raise
money in four months how are we going to
do that great per alive kind of and you
have those people then you need to be
able to recognize them that are there
for this
stressful moments
and be able to gather them around build
plan around that and then
at the moment that it
starts being created you already come up
with a plan right you already have hey
we already looked at this in the eye
where they looked at horror movies and
this is what we think is going to happen
we're gonna have an all end
every three days to start talking about
that we're gonna freeze hiring tomorrow
we're gonna stop coming to the and that
became kind of like military right it
was kind of something like that and we
started preparing for that in January
where everything closed in March right
so
it was kind of right here is a fear if
that comes true so so that's maybe an
extreme example but it comes in many
other things or sometimes see
entrepreneurs or companies kind of go
around their problem or rate to say hey
we don't have product Market fit for
this product
it's not working we can't pass the hump
of uh early adopters to early majority
which is not there something is missing
right and the ability to stare at it at
the eye add the model and say hey we're
failing here let's put all of our
resources to that problem
I think that helped us in many
situations and saved us even though it
was hard the required a lot of sacrifice
but it was uh for so far it's been worth
it
God thank you so much for this time and
yeah the openness and authenticity I
really really appreciate it and can't
wait to continue cheering from the side
and seeing all the amazing things that
that you're doing so so thank you and
best of luck thank you very much yeah
thanks a lot and thanks for having me
and good luck